ein top model auf dem laufsteg paul
woche bei der schau des belgischen
designer dries van noten in paris ein
paar stunden zuvor sieht dennoch eher
aus wie ein typischer tourist doch wenn
der 26-jährige durch paris spaziert kann
es zu ungewöhnlichen begegnungen kommt
paul woche trifft auf paul woche hier in
einer aktuellen werbekampagne von kenzo
wenn man sich so selbst auf dem bild
sieht das ist erstmal ungewohnt aber ich
mache das ja schon eine weile ist nicht
das erste bild das ich hänge sehr die
kampagne macht einfach spaß und ich bin
stolz dass zu sehen und irgendwie auch
zum kleinen schmunzeln auf den lippen
wenn ich vorbei laufen geboren wurde
paul woche in einer kleinen
thüringischen stadt seit fünf jahren
lebt er in berlin und in new york unter
vertrag ist er bei der größten pariser
männer model agentur banana us models
mit seiner agentin bespricht er die
letzten engagement und die nächsten
termine auf der pariser modewoche was
ihn ausmacht er ist pünktlich und sehr
höflich zu den kunden das ist wichtig
und er hat den körper den man braucht er
ist schlank aber nicht zu schlank
die kleider passen perfekt deswegen wird
er so oft für schon gebucht entdeckt
sollte von einem modelscout in berlin
auf der straße deutsche 16 jahre alt
schlagt auf dich zu und sagt möchtest du
zurück zur arbeit und habe die website
aufgerufen und lässt seinen irgendwie ja
das widget aus und meine eltern
angerufen und die dann auch irgendwie
nicht das angebot angenommen
eine begegnung die sein leben veränderte
heute zählt der deutsche zu den
gefragtesten männer models ein
wandelbares aussehen lässt ihn mal weich
und androgyn mal männlich markant
erscheinen trotz seines erfolges sieht
er die modeszene durchaus kritisch es
ist nicht so einfach wie man sich das
vorstellt
und es ist ein job der einsam machen
kann
die ablehnung natürlich alltäglich es in
dem beruf mit der muss man lernen
umzugehen
auf der anderen seite macht einen auch
stärker
weiter geht es zum fitting für die show
von dries van noten zu fuß über die
plaste la concorde mit einem kurzen
blick auf den eiffelturm
mehr zeit bleibt nicht
auch männer models müssen drei stunden
vor beginn der show erscheinen hier im
pariser grand palais
es wird basiert rasiert geschminkt und
geprobt für ein topmodel w poll woche
gehört das zum alltag
einmal aufrecht brust raus damit man
einfach gerade die kleidung nicht
irgendwie die schultern hängen lässt
konferenz selbstbewusst der belgier
dries van noten buch den jungen
deutschen regelmäßig seine neueste
kollektion ist vom ballett inspiriert
auf dem laufsteg zieht paul woche mit
seinem markanten look die blicke auf
sich
sein stil unterscheidet sich von dem der
anderen mut bei ihnen kommt jedes meiner
kleidungsstücke besonders zu gelten
er hat diesen gesichtsausdruck und sich
zu bewegen die sehr bewundert neben dem
modeln strebt vollbach eine zweite
karriere als schauspieler new york nimmt
der unterricht ich war ja schon in einem
musikvideo in kurzfilmen und
theaterstücken zu sehen es mit der
schauspielerei das ist dass es fast
klang irgendwie da ist künstler zu sein
also das weiß ich einfach es gibt viele
medien mit denen ich mich beschäftigt
habe mit denen ich mich mit sicherheit
auch weiter noch beschäftigen werde aber
aber das gefühl auf der bühne zu stehen
ist einzigartig und wenn man genau
hinschaut hat er da nicht etwas vom
jungen klaus kinski doch jetzt geht es
für paul woche erstmal zur nächsten
probe bei den modeschauen in paris